[Music]
hi friends and family of the drew
barrymore show i'm danny souter aka
blonde in the district and i'm coming to
you straight from our nation's capital
washington dc to show you my hometown
spirit
so to kick things off since we are in
washington dc i have to share with you
the national mall
the national mall is an amazing place to
come to see the capital the washington
monument and from here you can access
all of our amazing museum which all
happens to be free
win-win
another perk of coming down to the
national mall is you never know what
you're gonna find down here case in
point right behind me a beautifully
perfectly restored 1970 dodge challenger
pretty cool right
[Music]
another great thing about dc is all of
the amazing small local businesses and
shops that we have here in the city and
one of my favorites is goodwood dc
goodwood is such a great spot for
effective pieces one-of-a-kind things
and things that you won't find anywhere
else
next up is union market district which
is one of my favorite favorite areas of
dc this is an awesome spot to come for
great restaurants and food shopping a
budding art scene and the best part
about it is everything here is local and
community focused let's go
one of my favorite foods here in union
market are the knishes from buffalo
bergen
yum
okay friends that's a wrap i hope to see
you in dc very soon
[Music]
you